[Music]
let's go to emily in atlanta georgia hey
emily what's up
hi dr john how are you i'm good how are
you
i'm well thank you excellent what's up
how can i help
okay so um
my question is how do i keep my marriage
like fun and silly
spontaneous and whatnot
um when
those were a bunch of words for sexy is
am i am i right okay all right how do
you keep your marriage sexy when
um
when my husband is constantly making
jokes or innuendos that make me feel
uncomfortable because my kids are around
gross
why does he do that
um our kids are really young we have
three kids two and under okay um and so
i think
i think it stems from because
while before we had kids i mean
we just lived on our own and it was you
know two years ago we could say whatever
we wanted whenever we wanted yeah but
now i think my husband still lives in
that that our kids don't understand
um
but i guess i have a
fear that because we have all boys that
they're going to pick up on this and
think it's okay to treat women in a way
that makes them feel uncomfortable
or
you know
make comments about what they're wearing
and
not understand that that's just not what
i'm allowed to do because i'm a man or
something like that gotcha um
and so i've i've explained this to my
husband and so it seems like it's a
roller coaster like he'll do better for
a little while and then he'll
kind of revisit this behavior so to
speak where i'm like dude i want to be
comfortable in my house like and i'm not
comfortable making these jokes around my
my kids
um
even though they're not receptive to it
now i just think that one day they will
be sure and i'm afraid that this problem
so to speak won't be
handled by then and then it feels like
it will be too late that this will be
ingrained in them okay
so let me ask you a few clarifying
questions number one thanks for
articulating that uh uh there's a lot
there um
before you had kids
yes
if he told you something that he saw
thought you were sexy or you wore
something and he's like man
like i got five minutes if you got five
like he
he was in it did you like that or i mean
was that something that was attractive
to you you liked being your husband
thinking you were sexy and and wanting
to be with you or did that make you
uncomfortable then
at that point at me i was fine with that
i was okay with it because it was rare
not finding that not finding okay
like didn't yeah i was i was comfortable
with it like i accepted it i liked it
okay okay well received okay so well res
is what i'm getting at is was it
something that you just tolerated that's
his weird thing that he likes to and
was that a weird yeah you tolerated a a
strange sexual perversion he has and
it's not but i'm just just go with my
language there right
or did you like no it was awesome i like
being recognized no yeah it was awesome
it was rare then because before we had
kids my husband he's a reserved person
as it is so it's
it was rare then it seems like it's
amped up since we've had kids and maybe
it's because
um
like you're not able to have sex with
officers yeah there you go that's
exactly where i was headed so
so he had a thing
that
worked
when he used it
and the work in his head and again he's
not here to defend himself so i'm just
getting inside of his head which is the
thing i tell people never to do but this
is a radio show here we go
um is he knows he had one thing or maybe
two things or whatever who knows
that
would make your eyes squint a little bit
right
and
now
you're you'll have two little you have
two little ones right how old
no we have three little ones we have
one that's almost a year and then we
have two
twin boys that are almost three years
oh my gosh y'all y'all are probably
getting close to the the bi-annual sex
plan right now with three little kids
right
oh yes so you've got three tiny ones and
you've got a husband who misses you
yeah and we can we can say it's about
set he misses you
right
and of course there's sexuality and all
that but he misses intimacy with his
wife and so yeah now he's doubling down
on the only thing he knows
here's the conversation that has to
happen and you you did man i'm proud of
you first first question i always ask in
these situations is have you actually
told them and you have which is great
um
i i think what the conversation you'll
have to have is a deeper one
because it's not just about the comments
because the comments are he's only got
one path
to connection with you to intimate
connection with your right to sex
right the path below that is
oh my gosh we have three little kids
what's happening a to our marriage
b
like
how do we re-engage intimacy into this
and it's not
through you telling me making sexualized
jokes about my body
in front of my three little kids that's
the least sexy
the last way to get me in bed is this
yes
what you are going to have to think
through is what does
what is a an environment that he can
help create
that would allow you to feel sexy again
okay
so you tell me what are a couple of
things
let me back emily nagatsky says the
off's off and the ons on and i love that
what are the things that turn
this environment into a
hotter environment for lack of better
terms and what are the things that make
it cold
i think and i've talked about on the
show
having dishes in the sink for some
reason
makes my wife
i'm out
i've got to get that done before and you
know what i mean
and then there's other things that i'm
like i'm out and vice versa right so i
know now i just i'm gonna make sure the
dishes are listening
just i'm just gonna make sure that's a
part of my life right what are some
things that would be ons for you
environmentalism
kids asleep yeah
um
yeah cleaned up after dinner after the
day have all the toys away and
probably a clean bedroom
so that there's nothing to think about
other than what's going on not like the
laundry sitting in the corner or
something you know like that those are
probably the top three just clean house
all together
clean space
for sexual activity and then the kid's
asleep
what does he do for a living
my husband's in the air force air force
okay
is he a pilot what does he do
no he's um security forces okay so let's
let's pretend he's a pilot this may be a
good analogy
you have to make sure that plane has
been checked over
is all the electronics are working all
the systems are working all the radars
and all that stuff's working and the
cockpit has to be clean because those
things are there's a tight space there
right they have to be clean they have to
be spotless
and then somebody's going to get in that
thing and fly that plane
right
and so
he's got to know that there's an
environment here
and if you sit down and say hey
i need you to know
like nothing makes me more out of the
mood
than looking over and seeing my three
little boys watch you
talk to me about my body
okay but
here's what super would get me in the
mood
if you would take bedtimes
three nights a week
if when you walk in the door i know
you're tired but if you just did a scan
of this living room and made sure the
toys are up
if i'm taking a shower after the kids
are in bed
if you would just run through this
bedroom and make sure it's picked up
i'm gonna rock your ever-loving world
right and
here's the thing for you
is when we get out of step with intimacy
i wish there was another way to say this
because it sounds so perfunctory but
we have to practice our way back into
intimacy and practice our way back into
desire
and that means you have to know
i i may not be interested right now but
if we get going i'm gonna love this
right okay and so it's it's you
practicing it's him practicing it's you
being very clear here's here's the offs
for me
and here are the ons and the ons are
simple you don't even have to say
anything about my body anymore i know
i'm smoking hot you married me let's
move past that the kids don't need to
know that
and
here's what would really help out it
would free my soul to be all about you
and not all about this and this and this
and this and this and this and this and
this
and dude you'll be giving him the
greatest gift
any spouse could give their their their
other partner and that's clarity and a
path to me
okay
i do have one question with that my
husband is is really great about
helping out taking i'm definitely in
this season of life i'm definitely a
like a
an acts of service love language
receiver and so
he is really awesome about doing that
already
and
i know you had mentioned that i'm going
to have to practice getting back into
intimacy and whatnot
but what about the times that he does
all those things and that it's still
just a no from me because i feel like
it though all those things can be done
but it still could have been a really
tough day with the kids because i'm at
home with them all day long um
and i'm just like
no and that's like five days in a row
because they are long tough days yeah
is there a
so one totally honor that totally get
that
is there a way that you find rest and
release
through that with him or no
not really
and
it's important for you to be honest
about that
right because some of that may be
hormonal and i've told yeah and so that
may be hormonal some of that may be just
seasoned right now
some of that may be
there's a hundred different reasons why
that might be right yeah um
when you get going
are you glad that you got going or no is
it still a chore all the way through
depends on the
depends on the time
i would say like 50 50. like half the
time i'm like let's get this over with
and another half of the time i'm like
all right i'm here like this is great
what are the what are the what are the
differences in those two
um
the difference is i would say i
and not to cite my husband he's a
wonderful guy but sometimes i just feel
like he comes to me like a teenage boy
and whatnot and i'm like
okay yeah let's just get this over with
so that you can leave me alone for three
nights
we can revisit this when things start
peaking again for you and i'll just deal
with it then
um and part of that is like i'm
i'm the emotional regulator for three
little ones and myself all day long and
so i'm like you come to me like this and
even though you've done all the things
the cleaning of the house or just
whatever all those things are done or
we've taken care of them together and
whatnot it's like i feel like i'm back
to emotionally regulating
for somebody else
and i don't want to do that
at the end of my day i want to like
sit down and just do or take care of the
things that need to be taken care of and
whatnot um
there's a lot of me that's like
you deal with you and i'll deal with me
and then we can just come together and i
know that's awful but it just feels like
some nights that's what it is and i
can't
so i'm just like
emily i want to give you
a brief pass for a second
you have two three-year-olds and a
one-year-old
yeah
this isn't forever
yeah this is a season
okay
and
there is
this level i i know you've talked to him
have you ever said that what you just
said
yeah i've said that before
have you given him another way another
path to you that's not a middle school
boy or a high school boy
like have you articulated what that
means
i've articulated that i feel like
um well
i said it in different ways but it all
kind of leads back to that okay i want
you to think about it and think about
the clarity there because when you say
hey you i feel like you're just coming
at me like a middle school boy
my guess is again he's not here to
defend himself my guess is he's thinking
this is how we've always interacted
i've always told you that i think of
nothing but you and i want you and you
are all into that and now it's shifted
and suddenly he's feeling chastised for
the way y'all used to communicate
and so
it's not that the way you feel is wrong
the way you feel is right it's the way
you feel
and i'll say the way that he used to
come at you was how what you loved it's
about developing a new way
and so by just by saying hey
this is no good anymore which is
not only fine it's beautiful it's we go
all of us shift and change throughout
our marriage it's great
but it's what's the next path and i love
to hear you say no sometimes it's all in
sometimes there's things about the way
he comes at me or the way we end up
together that are incredible
and other times they're not other times
i feel like he's just being a middle
school boy and i'm just some girl on the
playground and
it's being able to say this is what made
this
completely on and this is what made this
off
okay and he's gonna have to practice new
ways of
coming at his wife
yeah and you are gonna have to give
yourself some grace sister because
you got two three-year-olds and a
one-year-old yeah
everything is bananas
and
contin
expect your desire to be low because
your body is taking care of three other
humans and in some ways it sounds like a
fourth human too
emotionally
give yourself some space and some peace
there and
remember he's practicing in a new way of
coming at his wife and he needs your
help for clarification what what are
ways
that best bring him to you and
you're gonna get back into practicing
desire and desire is gonna look
different now like you say when we were
young and married and he would come home
smoking out air force guy it was on like
d kong and now it's different because we
got three little ones
right okay is it fair
yeah that and that all sounds exactly
right but he is just doing what he's
always practiced and i'm not giving him
a clear another clear path so
and he might come and say
occasionally
i want to pretend like we're in college
again
yeah
and that will be his weird little
college fantasy and then you can decide
whether you're in on that one or not
right we all everyone in the world's got
like what if we uh you know whatever
um and so
every couple's got those kind of things
to navigate and work through
but
this is the moment when couples go oh
this is going to be the rest of our
lives we're falling apart things are
broken this is going to be it forever
and
it's not
it's just a small season
just a small season
i love that you have these conversations
i love it i love it i love it i love it
i love it
the the the future for your marriage is
bright to be honest with them and always
look to create new paths towards each
other because the old paths don't always
work anymore